[Music]
you know what that is don't you
you know what that is it's a little
house on the prairie theme song baby
the Daniel Caine Orchestra remember that
let's hear that intro again dude that
dirty trick was it trumpet a horn
that's it that is it the Little House on
the Prairie theme song God that was a
good one one of my favorite shows of all
time some people know that some people
don't now you know it Michael Landon
brah I bring this to you it is January
16th
it's 12:40 a.m. I had a show tonight at
the Hollywood improv and afterwards I
had a fan of my friend I say a friend a
lady that I've met through comedy
brought me two shirts as a gift one of
them had you know who your boy Michael
Landon on the front Oh beautiful shirt
dude some type of cotton black cotton or
something and another shirt it said all
day I dream about Michael Landon now
that one might be a little bit of a
reach but still you got to love Michael
Landon I grew up watching a little house
on a prairie it was like the only time
my brothers and sisters and I would sit
together and sheer joy was in the
morning it came on every morning on TBS
and it still does actually I might come
when the afternoons now but came on
every morning Little House on the
Prairie if you don't notice show it's
about a man and his children and they
just doing their best bro they're doing
their best and I loved it dude we would
sit there and watch it we would fight to
be in front of the TV we have like this
12-inch color TV I think it was color I
don't remember I was a kid so even if
it's black and white when you're a kid
you can imagine there's color there but
man we would sit and watch the episodes
I found an episode here online the first
season first episode Little House on the
Prairie the episode called a harvest of
friends bruh
i'ma read to you the synopsis of it the
original air date September 11 1974 in
the first episode of season 1 the
Ingalls that's the family settle on the
banks of
Plum Creek Charles asked the Olsens for
credit to buy a plow and seed but they
explained they can only offer credit to
farmers they've known for a long time
dun-dun-duh
Charles ends up making a deal with mr.
O'Neill in exchange for a plow and seed
Charles agrees to repair O'Neill's roof
and stack his grain within three weeks
after completing the roof Charles
decides to take the family on an all-day
picnic to make up for the time he's
spent working
unfortunately he falls out of a tree
while trying to retrieve a kite oh that
kite hustle and breaks his ribs O'Neill
assumes Charles won't be able to stack
the grain and takes the oxen a day early
losing the oxen brah Charles can't
afford to lose the oxen and tries to
stack the grain with broken ribs he
collapses and then Laura and Mary start
stacking the grain dr. Baker mr. Hanson
and mr. Olsen and other townspeople see
the girls struggling and team up to
stack all the grain allowing Charles to
keep his oxen that's teamwork bro that's
family man
you can't stack the grain you can't get
the job done your neighbors come to help
you bro that's what I love that think
that's what I loved about it man just
seeing like camaraderie and teamwork cuz
it wasn't like that in my neighborhood
dude brah
man I'm remember first time ever pulled
up into my neighborhood growing up
because my parents got divorced I end up
and we end up in this shitty
neighborhood and uh and the first day we
got there this man these two grown men
this man this older man he was a senior
citizen he was fighting a bus driver
they were fighting in the street a
school bus driver school bus driver he
didn't wear a shirt you know he chose
not to wear shirts or just didn't do
shirts but they were fighting and they
had a ditch
and a ditch fire instead of you know
waiting for somebody to come and get
your trash people would just burn all
their trash in the ditch you know is I
mean I guess it could have created some
carbon monoxide issues or you know it
could have affected the environment I
don't know we didn't have an environment
so anyway the bus driver threw this old
dude into the ditch fire bro the old
dude everybody's like you know going
over to try to help but then this old
dude Brooke gets wiry cuz you know old
dude's got old dude strength this dude
just got up out of the fire his arm was
still burning he had flames coming off
his back and he went and attacked the
dude again bruh attack the bus driver
and that was the first day of or spent
in my neighborhood when I saw that [ __ ]
I was like damn man we're [ __ ] my
family is [ __ ] so yeah that was my old
neighborhood so I think when I saw
things like Little House on the Prairie
with like camaraderie they had a doctor
if you got a hurt like they had to do it
in my neighborhood they got hurt he
broke his clavicle right and or his
collarbone or wish collarbone and he
just his shirt never fit the same it
just he didn't nobody took him to a
doctor he just his shirt and never fit
right again you know one of his he had
kind of that slope coming in a little
bit on the left I mean he couldn't you
couldn't he couldn't keep a raindrop on
his shoulder that's for damn sure
so anyway man I guess I loved Little
House on the Prairie and tonight
somebody bought me this Michael Landon
t-shirt put it up on my Instagram's
it was cool man it was just nice it was
like a nice thing I didn't expect you
know that's nice when something happens
it's unexpected that's a beautiful thing
I got to remember to try to do that more
often for other people just do something
nice you know dude I always wanted to
break into somebody's house and install
an alarm they used to be like kind of
this idea of mine like I'm gonna break
in
and install an alarm but then I thought
what if you break in somebody's air you
get shot up then you can't be like you
know don't shoot me I'm here to put in
an alarm I just don't know if they would
buy it
so maybe I'm I'm just gonna sit on that
idea bro i'ma sit on the I must sit on
that idea but but ring the good idea
bell because that is a good idea that is
a good idea good to chat with you or be
here it is Monday January 16th it's
actually Sunday night I haven't gone to
bed yet it is
12:48 a.m. Pacific Standard Time and I
had a pretty good weekend man would you
do well do you watch some football
probably huh
did you watch some football there's a
lot of good games on man I threw a
little wager damn I bet bet on today's
games I bet Pittsburgh I took Pittsburgh
and a point and I bet I bet Green Bay
would win that was a game huh what about
that footwork by Aaron Rodgers he don't
need he barely even separates his legs
he's just like a little dancer out there
he's just like a little he's just like a
little he just kind of like just Muay
just he's like a little like Billy
Elliot you know he's like Billy Elliot
from that British movie you know I'm not
too poor Todd it's about a young young
gentleman his father thinks that he's
homosexual because he wants to dance but
he's not you know or he maybe who knows
that it doesn't really go all into that
but he just wants to be a dancer man and
I'll be honest with you I think I could
have been a dancer bro I mean there days
do when I get well my feet just feel
light you know and I really feel like I
could have made a name for myself and
some of those you know some of those
circles some of those dancing circles
but I just didn't have the I didn't have
a support when I was younger emotionally
to tell me it's okay to get out there
and dance you know I just didn't have it
man I didn't have it so if you got a kid
that wants to dance
get him some dancing shoes man you know
I could still tap-dance I actually I met
a guy yesterday who was an adult tap
dancer he was dressed like he was from
Boardwalk Empire kind of so that was a
little bit squirrely but he's an adult
tap dancer and and I talked to him about
it a little bit I will say it did seem a
little strange when he just started just
dropping feet everywhere like he would
just break into some you know just fancy
footwork so maybe it's not for me I
don't know I thought it felt like Jesus
Christ somebody [ __ ] you know get
this dude a gameboy or something you
know get to somebody get this guy a
Playstation 6 or something I don't know
I don't know but yeah Green Bay won that
game huh
what a game both games do it and then
the Dallas fans I'm if you heard this
Dallas fans they had a bunch of severe
storms in the area and tornadoes some of
them had to stay they weren't allowed to
leave the stadium like that and that's
obviously the last ones the most
inebriated ones they're stuck in their
media all the media was stuck in there
some of the players were stuck there so
apparently they were all just hanging
out on the middle of the field I bet
that was pretty interesting you know I'd
be pissed though you know you're
starving your team lost $14 hotdogs it's
all they got for sale you know the
cheerleaders are all fully dressed now
I'm out Jerry Jones probably just
offered him like some cups of water or
something you know nothing fancy I don't
know I don't know watch it game it was
good man that Pittsburgh game looked
cold didn't oh those guys are freezing
cold I don't know if I could do it I'm
at the age now where I think I've given
up look there weren't there were years
where I would watch football and be like
ah I could be out there even though I
never played football I've never played
it I played it at home you know we
played a we played three times a week in
our neighborhood I never played
organized football we didn't have any
health insurance
so I was always afraid you know we're
getting jacked up I'd just be that dude
you know I'd be like freaking to do with
the bat with the bad clavicle you know
the dude that can't hold a raindrop on
his shoulder bro I didn't want to be
like that you know that another man in
our town of Elvis impersonator I think
I'm I told this story actually but he
broke his leg and uh and they set it in
cement to save money and it healed up
fine but then they when they broke the
cast when they rewrote the cast they
broke it with a sledgehammer and Rhee
broke his leg and hip in about seven
places this dude he was Elvis
impersonator I think I think I mentioned
that anyway man what else is going on
Jimmy Snuka died Jimmy Superfly Snuka if
he knew this guy or not
he was a wrestler he was he was a raster
he was a raster professional wrestler
dude for I fit before I forget this I
was in the airport one time I saw
Evander Holyfield the boxer right famous
boxer got his ear bit off by Mike Tyson
I saw him in the airport in the airport
in Chicago a few years ago and he was
sitting at a McDonald's and the
McDonald's and a front porch it had like
a little outlet that you could sit there
and it kind of juddered out into the
terminal walkway so I'm walking along
and I see Evander Holyfield's he's just
sitting there and he's got a bunch of
fries man fries only nothing else just
fries and he was taking these fries he
was taking these fries and just shoving
them into his mouth and he couldn't even
he couldn't even open his mouth I don't
know if he just been punched so many
times or maybe he could open his mouth
he was just tired
you know I never been so tired that I
didn't open my mouth when I was putting
food in it I guess you could just shove
food through your frikken you know
through your freaking
flap curtain lips but he was just
shoving fries through his lips like it
was like kind of like at the UM whenever
you get your luggage at an airport if
you missed the luggage and it just goes
back through those black curtains you
know through the black plastic flaps it
was like that with him he was just
shoving these fries just threw his flaps
through his face flaps and uh I was
baffling to me I'm like maybe he'd been
beaten so bad he just can't open his
mouth anymore well anyway they had this
little lady
this young girl actually kind of a
middle aged child basically maybe 17 or
20 who worked down at the Cinnabon you
know the Cinnabon that's just a little
fat Center in the airport where they got
them good smells so you go over there
and they got 19 different sizes of uh a
cinnamon roll bra just I mean two bites
and you could just you feel like you got
to take a nap because your Sugar's all
up but this girl runs up evander is
sitting there too shoving fries through
his face flaps and this girl runs up and
she's just standing there right in front
of him and she goes and he looks over
and she goes oh I used to watch you
wrestle and did I bout lost my mind I
used to watch you wrassle wrassle - a
professional boxer I used to watch you
wrestle anyway that's my uh that's my
wrasslers story I was a big wrestling
fan Jimmy Superfly Snuka he died I think
he was in his 70s what does this say
here let me find it here Jimmy Snuka
yeah he died man he died
73 years old he died he had stomach
cancer kind of broke my heart when I
heard about it you know he was supposed
to go on trial I think recently
or was soon to go and trial fer yeah he
allegedly murdered his girlfriend not a
cool move you know not a cool move dude
he allegedly killed his girlfriend in
1983 but they dropped uh they dropped
the charges because he was gonna die I
guess he had terminal cancer and and
that was gonna be that and so they
dropped those charges but they found his
girlfriend in a hotel room I guess so a
long time ago in Pennsylvania and uh and
she wasn't living anymore
he said she fell down Yeah right dude
you're a raster bro
you know there was a body slam or a
frickin leg
gypsy hold or something frickin chop
something you did but yeah man Jimmy
Superfly Snuka dead he was the one man
he was the one growing up that had just
electrified me I loved wrassling you
know I grew up poor white those were our
heroes it seemed for some reason poor
white people we just we loved rasslin
brah I don't know what it is I don't
know if it's the abuse it's the steroids
it's the just how easy it is to to take
in you just believe it the you know for
some reason everybody in my neighborhood
loved rasslin we just believe in those
heroes man they could be those were our
heroes yeah the guy allegedly killed his
girlfriend now that I couldn't do man I
couldn't kill I couldn't kill my
girlfriend you know I've had let me see
three girlfriends which isn't really a
lot you know because I'm emotionally
damaged hard to connect sometimes but
I've had three girlfriends could I have
killed any of them yeah I could have
killed someone very bright so I could
have maybe not killed him I couldn't
have killed him no so I'm gonna say that
I couldn't have killed him I could have
got Aang I could have gotten so angry at
both of
that I could have driven us off of a
cliff or something like Thelma and
Louise I could have seen something like
that possibly you know if it was you
know say we're moving across country
together and you know and you know some
ignorant hits an all-time high I could
have just seen me for just veering us
off a cliff maybe I don't know New
Mexico maybe in New Mexico but yeah I
know but I couldn't I mean I kind of
like kill anybody I love murder shows
dude I mean I love murder shows buried
treasure that show disappeared where
people are dismissing Jesus I used to go
look in the woods when I was growing up
for missing people for missing bodies
and stuff I guess I thought when I was
young that like the woods behind your
house or near your house were like the
same woods everywhere you know that the
woods were the woods so whenever I would
watch those shows as unsolved mysteries
or America's Most Wanted and like a body
was missing I would be like ah it might
be in the woods so I go look and knowing
my neighborhood it could have been man
you know anything was possible they had
the first funeral I went to the dude
that got thrown in the ditch fire years
later he died right so I'm walking down
the street with my buddy Danny and he
was born with some deficiencies he had
extra salivary glands in his face so he
was always kind of spraying out of his
face when he would smile or feel real
joyous he would you know kind of spout
out at the corners of his mouth and uh
and then he also had like uh was born
with like a wrist in his neck like an
his neck had like a just an involuntary
spin to it about every maybe five
seconds his neck would just just flare
around you know just like a circle like
that you know just some just like it but
he would look to the left and then look
straight up and then to the right and
then back to Center just just
involuntarily anyway he and I are
walking down the street and the
and who got thrown in the ditch fire his
son was there and he said you guys want
to come to a service I didn't know what
a service was man I thought it was you
know I don't know what I thought it was
a I probably thought it was something
religious and I guess I was right in
that sense because we walk into the
backyard and they had buried the man
they had put him in a in a in a coffin
in a pine or something coffin maybe
could have been teak look pretty
something malleable malleable wood and
they put him in the ground and there was
some chairs set up some folding chairs
some of those kind of brown folding
chairs and we all sat there and they had
they read some scripture and then they
buried this man in the backyard and
they're like does anybody want to say
some words you know does anybody want to
say some words and I didn't know what to
say you know so I just you know try to
do this town of the Cross even though I
didn't know it and then Danny this dude
he said he stood up and said the grace
that you say before dinner you know
whatever it bless us O Lord and these I
guess we were about to receive that
bounty through Christ our Lord amen
and then like God we thank you for this
food I'm like and I'm thinking to myself
that's definitely not the [ __ ] prayer
you say when somebody's dying but he
didn't know any better anyway [ __ ]
that was it dude what what the hell man
thinking back that's just that's
baffling dude that we're standing next
to a funeral and he says grace he said
dinner grace whatever that's life dude
that's death but I loved wrestling bro
do my brother and I we stew push the
beds in our room and that would be like
two sides of the Ring and we would just
wrestle groan we had charts of like all
the different wrestlers and we we each
drew names and that's the rest
we were and whoever would win that
wrestler would be eliminated
man that was fun dude that was fun
those were the good old days man that's
what we did we got outside you know we
didn't have this before they had the
wrestling video game so we had to go do
it
you know whatever now they got the game
so these kids don't have to do it you
know we had to go impersonate those
adventures you know we couldn't just sit
in front of a TV and be a pilot or be a
I mean we had Super Mario and they had
some eventually John Madden came out but
before that we just had to go and
pretend we were these things so that's
sometimes my issue of video games is
that it just takes the place of an
imagination it's like why does it why
don't why don't I don't blame a kid they
don't know any better they don't have to
imagine anything any more if it can just
be presented to them in front of them
but anyway man that was that was wild
but yeah that Kansas City game look so
cold huh couldn't do it dude
I couldn't even go stay I wanted to live
in New York I wanted to stay there for a
little bit longer but I gotta wait till
it warms up I can't be there in the
winter like that just chills you chills
your bones just makes you feel like a
dead body that's still just walking
around what else man I've been watching
that show the Oh a have you seen this
it's on Netflix the Oh a I heard the
ending is horrible but everything before
the ending my god it's awesome bro it's
like people that had a near-death
experience and then they this scientist
I don't want to tell you what happens
but if you like it if you like a little
bit of kidnapping and some it's got some
light science fiction it's right on and
I don't know I heard the ending is not
good but I guess I'll just enjoy you
know the meantime that shows good dude
I want to watch shameless I haven't seen
that what else I don't know oh could I
kill my girlfriend I couldn't you know I
couldn't kill my girlfriend could I kill
someone
I don't think I could do it man I just
don't think I have it in me you know
and you got to hide the body that's the
thing too like I could understand how
people could kill someone in a fit of
rage something crazy happens their
psyche breaks and they just kill
somebody
you know but then you gotta hide the
body bro
nobody gets away with I mean so rare
with the DNA you got to make sure their
phone isn't around because the phone
sends a ping out apparently the towers
it's always like the phone was bouncing
off these towers you gotta clean up or
you gotta kill them real carefully I
guess like in a you know you got to
invite them over and just have this
clean all over your house maybe say some
painters are coming so that way you know
you're already prepared I couldn't do it
though you know
yeah I couldn't do it oh I hate that
dude I'd hate to get murdered I don't
want to get murdered I don't want to get
murdered dude hopefully I won't plain
crowd and hate a plain crowd that's got
to be the worst oh that's got to be the
worst what's the worst way to go anyway
I'm getting pretty dour here I'm getting
pretty pretty pretty damp here in my
words here at night it's late it's late
man this is what you get when it's late
I had a great show this weekend I worked
with Harlan Williams who I'm a huge fan
of you he was in half-baked you may know
him from and other things too but in
half-baked he had that scene where like
he's gonna feed the horse all those
groceries and he's like what can I get
for you big girl and he's talking to the
horse and uh and this black lady's
walking by and she thinks it he's
talking to her and she turns around and
she's like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
uh that was baffling to me man that [ __ ]
was hilarious so I got to work with
Harlan Williams dude and that was great
he came up to me afterwards and said
that he really loved my set which was
nice because you know when these old
comedians or comedians that have been
around longer they come around and say
something or any job you know you know
it always feels good to I think you know
when somebody who's better than you and
has more experience in you and somebody
you admire you know drop some good
knowledge on your drop some admiration
or just Pat's you on the back you know
so I gotta remember to try to do that
trying to be a better person that shit's
hard isn't it trying to be a better
person and live and just manage your
regular life at the same time it's hard
man it's not easy it's not easy we're
all trying hopefully we're all trying to
be better people I don't [ __ ] know
some days I just want to just get a
bunch of ice cream and just you know
just lay in the sheets and just try not
to do masturbation I gave in to some
masturbation this past week so you know
I'm back I'm empty you know you could
say it like that I mean that's just such
nature bruh you know I didn't want to do
it I guess I don't know I had that
moment where I was like God do I wanna
you know I know I want I want to but I
know in my brain that I don't want to
what do I do
well masturbation one bro it's a
powerful drug your own dick that's a
powerful drug your own crotch that's a
powerful drug oh we listen to this get
me back to sanity
[Music]
yeah you gotta help with those bags of
grain huh
you broke your ribs try playing in a
tree you got to help with those bags of
grain huh
help you a friend with his grain be a
good neighbor we don't even know who our
neighbors are anymore I always thought
that should have been a good a holiday
here's a holiday go next door find out
who the [ __ ] lives there dude we would
get it eliminate so many creepers just
like that so many so many of my friends
have no idea what their neighbor does
you know but we have no that's another
thing like I'm excited about having some
boarders in this country because we
don't even know who the [ __ ] is already
here it's scary it's scary living in a
country where you don't know who's the
ear you know that's bad that's crazy
that's like imagine you wake up and
there's some people in your house you
don't know huh who are you I'm huh
that's America man that's America
sometimes you know and I know it's like
you gotta be you know the land of the
open and you know the free and stuff
like that but I think sometimes we gotta
know who's here we need a roll call
that's what we need we need everybody's
third grade teacher to show up with the
pencil in their hair and do a roll call
or do like do like a boat safety drill
you know they do on a cruise they get
everybody out in the beginning you got
your group where you meet up you put on
your life jacket do that in the street
let's find out who our neighbors are
find out who's here [ __ ] creepy Magoo
Boursin down the street who is he I
don't know whatever dude it's just it's
obviously been a long weekend throw some
dates I got some new dates I'm coming to
Baltimore I'm coming to Baltimore dude
let me tell you the name of this club
bro just got it in here's the place it
is called Magoo B's comedy club that's
where I'll be
it's actually an timonium Maryland Feb
wearing 9th through the 11th so that's
Thursday Friday Saturday McGoo B's
comedy club in timonium I know where
that is it sounds like something I
should get inoculated for timonium
Marilyn let's see what it is who is a
racetrack there is about 99 hundred
people live there who would they want to
bring the dog in her they want to bring
him in the timonium yes I'll be there
I'll be there out in timonium it looks
like it is near it's about yeah right
outside of Baltimore Northside of
Baltimore
outside of that I'll be at Virginia
Beach funnybone coming up January 26
through 29th and then I'll be at the
Schomburg improv outside of Chicago
February 2nd through 4th and the Comedy
Works in Denver that's February 23rd
through 26th so I'm excited about that
and what else happened man this past
weekend just did some sets man Harlan
Williams saying some nice things that
was cool just trying to be a decent man
that's what else is going on you know
I'm trying to stay out of the politics
it's hard not to talk politics man just
so many Pete just I just don't know how
they get people to see each other's
perspectives people have different
perspectives like people live in
different worlds like out here in
California a lot of these people out
here they live like it's just a
different world
they can't even fathom the environment
that I grew up in or the environment
that a lot of people grew up in you know
people that are well-off they have no
idea what life is like when they're not
well-off and there's nothing wrong with
that but the problem is that people just
see the world completely differently
like they can't see my perspective and I
can't see their perspective so sometimes
it's just baffling how people feel like
we live you know in this same universe
you know like people out on the west
coast are always like you know
no more racism no more you know it's
like we don't need and it's true you
don't need those types of things
you don't need racism it's horrible but
then you get in but they don't
understand how people who were living
environment in environments where there
is racism they don't know what that's
like
you know it's totally different when
you're living in an environment where
there is a lot of racism it's just
baffling man it's and it's different
it's like we just need to swap places I
don't know how we do it maybe virtual
reality you know I heard that there's
gonna be virtual reality this is true
these if I can find this article virtual
reality where you can experience
different races let me see I saw this a
while back I'm just looking it up on the
Google here top four shots to go by now
reset no the experience it's no
ethnicities this this [ __ ] is baffling
dude virtual real virtual body-swapping
a [ __ ] I don't know but yeah I heard
there's a virtual reality where you
gonna be able to see what it's like to
be different ethnicities you can put on
like Latino and walk down the street I
guess in this virtual area and and
you'll be you'll see what it's like and
that's it I just don't know if that is
that gonna help you maybe that'll help
maybe that will help maybe that's what
we need you know maybe we need to show
each other what it's like to have lived
each other's lives maybe virtual reality
can actually can that do that but is
that going to change our minds but it's
just gonna change what we see you know I
don't know man but it's crazy sometimes
out here in California is just like
people it's just like people don't see
that the rest of the that America is
different or they don't care you know
like I'm amazed at all these celebrities
that just bash you know that bash like
I mean the poor white people are like
the punching bag of America right now
and that's kind of hard for me because I
grew up poor and white you know and I
don't think poor white people are bad
people I don't think anybody are bad
people it's just I don't know [ __ ] it
whatever it just it's tough man it's
tough out here it's tough sometimes
especially having like a southern accent
people think immediately I'm just stuff
you know some yokel you know it's just I
don't even know I'm talking about anyway
I'm going off at least I'm not a Dallas
fan whoo God that must have hurt huh but
they got young players you know Ezekiel
Elliott that guy ah getting him on my
fantasy squad definitely next year what
else man Jimmy Snuka died we went over
that trying to see if there's anything
else really exciting I was gonna tell
you guys about the weekend was pretty
chill man I went over to some friends um
you know went over some friends who
watched the Atlanta game that [ __ ] was
pretty dope you know they had some kids
that there were obviously big Atlanta
fans some pictures of Paris jacks and I
just saw Michael Jackson's daughter dude
she looks like she's attractive young
lady I don't know how old she is you
know that's why I'm not gonna say
anything more but she looks 18 she's an
attractive young lady that's got to be
crazy Michael Jackson was your dad can
you even imagine all the NDA's you had
to sign growing up can you even imagine
it's gotta be bizarre um but that's it
man that's what's going on this past
weekend I don't really have a ton so I'm
not gonna take up a lot of your time but
I'll check in again next weekend we're
gonna get some video options we're gonna
get are gonna start doing some guests
I'm open to any constructive criticism I
don't know if this is a good idea to
just get on here and share you know
always second-guess myself I've always
been that kind of person that you know
just second-guesses themselves you know
I wish I wasn't sometimes I wish I was
more confident and sometimes I am it's
getting better you know I'm almost six
months sober or having drank you know
mmm
drinking so that's exciting for me man
on the 17th so that's pretty dope dude
so that's one cool thing and I've been
enjoying that you know I know that's a
buzzkill to a lot of my fans who wanted
to buy me a beer but you can still buy
me a beer just make it a ginger beer bro
you know what I'm saying let's do that
dude but anyway a breakdown from this
weekend oh I was thinking about some
sounds that I make dude I was thinking
about like like when I get angry this is
sound of me thinking about that one
that's the one I make a lot do you like
when I'm really upset [ __ ] [ __ ]
I did that one trying to think of one
that I do like when I'm in the car I do
that one I'll drop some or sometimes up
mostly in the morning like right when I
get up if I'm gonna shower music I kind
of pissed off I'll just belt out a
series of just every racial slur that
they ever made I'll belt it out just to
get them all out of my system you know
I'll do that in the morning I'm gonna
think about that I'm thinking about some
sounds that I make I'm gonna try to pay
attention to some to some sounds that I
make in the next week and I'll bring
them back for you guys next week but
that's it man that's what's been going
on if you have anything you want me to
discuss on here or talked about we got
Adam Carolla coming up on allegedly on
the allegedly podcast that I do with
Matthew Cole Weiss you can check that
out that's gonna be released tomorrow
that's allegedly and it's on iTunes we
got Adam Carolla Margaret Cho is our
just our guest that was a great episode
she talked about how when she was
hanging out with John Travolta one time
and he ate an entire pie by himself
could you even imagine sitting there
watching wrong beautiful old blue eyes
Travolta frickin smug and down a pie
like Evander Holyfield you used to I
used to watch you wrestle I used to
watch you wrestle
oh it was good man the old days huh I
miss him I miss him always long for the
old days man what else I'll try to give
you a personal update what's going on
man
copped a little bit of oral copped a
little bit of oral recently so that was
good you know you know I don't know if
I've got to read up on oral oral sex and
see what the history of that is and I'll
try to do that for next week oral sex
and maybe some different sounds that I
make not during oral sex but just during
life different life sounds I'm making a
chart for next week oral sex but yeah
copped a little bit of oral you know
it's always good to keep your vibe going
you know get out there and you know
experience somebody else's face or mouth
with part of your body I think that's
good for men and women a lot of these
women are just you know offering aural
these days to you know you know they
were just like it wasn't probably two
months ago this girls like you want to
come around this building and just you
know chew on my frickin little birth
wallet and I'm like whoa lady you know
that's pretty bizarre it's quite an
offer you know just traipse around the
the corner of a building and fricking
snack on the end of somebody's berth
wallet I'm out I'm out lady all right I
think that maybe wraps it up dude I had
some fans that sent in some music some
opening music maybe I'll try to use that
next week some cool tune that they made
but that's it man you know I'm just
trying to stay positive this week was a
little tough I got down in the doldrums
kind of it's kind of hard when that
happens brah stay on my meds you know
keep my meds tight I stay focused you
know I get out of myself spend time with
friends I call friends constantly see
how they're doing
this week I'm excited this week we got a
couple of cool guests for the podcast we
got Aaron Carter coming in now to be
interesting to see what his life's been
like he's like a young musician dude and
then cinnamon I'm excited for the games
next week Atlanta and Green Bay I'm
gonna go with Green Bay I think it's
gonna be a Green Bay New England's Super
Bowl and that would be a rematch I think
they played years ago in New Orleans I'm
not sure but at least I'm not a Dallas
fan tonight
sorry about that Dallas fans KC fans I
love you guys you're out in the cold in
Dallas fans you gonna have a great team
for a while so everything will be okay
at least nobody's a Saints fan we got to
get rid of Sean Payton do it anybody
thinks that that guy he thinks he's Bill
Belichick but his he's not he's not that
he's had five defensive coordinators oh
they're all the problem huh Sean with
your booty hole mouth he got a mouth
like a booty hole like a sphincter look
at his mouth next time saw it like just
like a sphincter imagine somebody took I
bet his his booty hole looks like a
regular mouth I bet I bet that and on
that note man this is this past weekend
let me know any constructive criticisms
man I really I love it if you love the
podcast comment on it on iTunes say
something nice and be good to yourselves
man you know if you're being hard on
yourself if you're trying too hard
take a break you know let some light
into your life you know I asked God for
help you know ask your friends for help
or help a friend quit thinking about
yourself if you can it'll make
everything easier man it always does I'm
not trying to preach at you I'm just
trying to be here with you but uh I love
you guys I'm trying to love myself we'll
see how it goes
and this is Monday January 16th 2017 and
this is this past weekend thank you
take us home Charles Ingalls Laura
remember a little Laura got she would
have been made a good sister Mary Mary
went blind twice God what are the odds
you go blind she got kicked by a horse
once and then another time but they get
just like severe Sun lighter I saw a flu
god er she got blind again Jesus Christ
oh the kids were blind and the mother
she never changed clothes of her nine
seasons of television now that's a lady
huh the dress she wear that dress and
that apron and sometimes the hair bonnet
but sometimes at night she would take
her hair down but still have on her day
clothes for night clothes oh that was
teamwork ah then the grain help your
neighbor with his grains for the love of
Christ you guys be good men I'll see you
next week